Jarrid Kushner's lawyer is pushing back
after a Senate committee said president
Trump's son-in-law had not been fully
forthcoming in its investigation into
Russian interference in last year's
presidential election Kushner's attorney
says his client encouraged others in the
Trump campaign to decline meetings with
foreigners Jeff Pegues has new details
CBS News has learned that in May of 2016
there was a request for a meeting with
then candidate Trump by two Russian
nationals the request is at the center
of the Senate Judiciary Committee's
demand for more information from Jared
Kushner on Thursday the committee asked
for additional information from Kushner
about a quote Russian back door overture
and dinner invite a source says among
the documents that congressional
investigators want is a request for a
meeting from man named Alexander tortion
and a woman reported to be torsions
assistant maria boo tina tortion has
ties to the Kremlin and according to
publish reports is also suspected of
having ties to organized crime according
to the source tortion and boo tina were
hoping to meet then candidate Trump and
were eager for mr. Trump to travel to
Russia to meet with Russian President
Vladimir Putin the request was made
through an intermediary who was attached
to a National Rifle Association event in
Kentucky the email requesting the
meeting was eventually forwarded to
Kushner who according to a source
declined the meeting Anthony Jeff the
gaze in Washington thanks Kushner's
lawyer Abbi Lowell released a statement
in which he quoted Kushner's email
saying he was passing on the meeting
according to low Kirchner's response was
quote a lot of people come claiming to
carry messages very few we are able to
verify for now I think we decline such
meetings most likely these people then
go back home and claim they have special
access to gain importance for themselves
be careful